if there was one startling fact that got
me going on this book it was realizing
the time travel is a new idea we're so
we're so familiar with it we grow up
with time travel we have time travel in
cartoons we know all of the jokes we
know the paradoxes it's black part of
our the fabric of our culture and it was
really a surprise to me to discover that
before HG Wells there was almost no
conception of time travel nobody put the
two words together there the time
machine his his 1895 book is really the
first time people thought there could be
such a thing as a time machine and
that's that just struck me as weird
because the your first impulse is you
want to argue with that probably I mean
a lot of people a lot of people think
well that can't possibly be true what
about this you know what about this
Greek legend what about what about
stories told by the ancient Japanese and
there are things where for example a
fisherman falls asleep and wakes up many
generations later and everybody he knows
is dead and that's like the Rip Van
Winkle's story and Rip Van Winkle was
before HG Wells of course they're not
that much more before and because we're
we have such an expansive sense of
time-travel ourselves and we're
imaginative people we can immediately
see that for example when the Greeks
imagined going down to the land of the
dead going to Hades and crossing the
river Styx
and meeting their dead ancestors that's
a kind of time travel we might say or
anyway if you're a sci-fi geek you might
be thinking of you know racking your
brain trying to think of of predecessors
and there are things there are sort of
weird things that if you're a geek you
can find but it's a it's the truth that
before the late Victorian era it was
practically impossible for
people to conceive of time travel and I
say it was impossible because they
didn't so it raises two questions - you
know mirror-image questions why not
before why did what was it that made
this not a natural way to think about
things and then the other question is
why now you know was there something
that it is HG Wells kind of an odd just
an oddball a one-and-one in a millennium
quirk or was there something in the
culture though is there something about
the times that made time-travel an
interesting or natural or plausible idea
and of course it's I think it's the
second thing and that's the print the
point of my book is to investigate these
questions or at least this I should say
the starting point of the book is to
investigate these questions one sort of
basic thing to say about why it wasn't a
natural idea is imagine imagine yourself
in the 16th century you're a farmer
let's say and somebody asks you so what
do you think life is going to be like
for your grandchildren you would say
what do you mean that question doesn't
that question doesn't make any sense
life is going to be the same for my
grandchildren life is the same for me as
it's always spin there's nothing
different about the world I live in from
the world of my known ancestors the
world wasn't changing fast enough for
anybody to have a sense of technological
progress much less a sense that
technological progress is kind of
inevitable that we are on a on a
conveyor belt bringing us inexorably
into the future right so you can see
that start to change during the
Industrial Revolution the pace of
technological change accelerates and it
accelerates to a point when suddenly
people can can look around and become
aware that things actually do change
fast in in 19th century England there
railroad trains and you could ride a
railroad train across the landscape and
look out the window and see you know a
farmer behind a plow with the same kind
of plow that that his ancestors had been
using for five hundred years and you're
hurtling across this landscape and you
would be acutely aware that your parents
didn't do that and at the same time the
telegraph arrived on the scene and
things started to change really fast and
you can see in the way people talked
about these technologies at the time
that they were very aware of these
changes they they spoke the way we the
way we do today about technological
change and how the world is being
transformed and for example the
Telegraph is annihilating space in time
that was part of the subject of my last
book on information so HG Wells in the
1890s is living in a world where it was
possible now for somebody like him and
he was an exceptional person to become
intensely curious about the future to
say the future is what I care about he
was able to think of himself as a kind
of futurist that was not a word that
really existed comfortably in the
language but he used it and he he felt
he because he was a forward-looking guy
you know politically forward-looking too
he was a socialist he thought the smart
people the cool people should be
thinking about what the future is like
and so that's another peculiar fact
about his book the time machine that not
everybody remembers that you know he had
this time machine and it could go
wherever he wanted but it only goes into
the future HG Wells never thought I can
travel into the past you know who would
I want to meet which is the kind of
thing we think all the time now right a
lot of a lot of time-travel stories
involve travel to the past
of course there's there's much more to
it there's there's much more going on
about notions of time and that that
becomes for me at least that was the fun
of the fun of doing the book was to see
what what was happening there was a kind
of ferment a kind of upheaval in the way
people were thinking about time part of
it had to do with discovery of geology
people were digging in the earth and
looking at buried layers since and and
understanding for the first time that
these layers of different kinds of rock
sedimentary volcanic rock were a kind of
diagram of the Earth's history and at
the same time Darwin had had arrived and
spoken and people were understanding
something for the first time about the
history of life on Earth and and the way
the history of life on earth could be
visualized and explored again through
buried layers so there's a kind of
spatial metaphor for time you can look
at the earth and archaeologists were
digging things up and realizing that
this is a kind of record and you can
think of time as something extending
deep into the earth for example I mean
there were a lot of new ways of looking
at time here's another example it comes
along with instrumentation for thinking
about the weather you have a barometer
and and it makes a graph of the air
pressure over time and so the needle
goes up and down and you look at this
graph on a paper and one of the
dimensions on the paper represents time
and that wasn't a totally new idea in
the 19th century Descartes did that and
Newton did it they graphed time against
space as a dimension but so there's
something that also was coming into
people's awareness and so a funny thing
about HG Wells's book
stick with him for a second is his time
traveler as he calls him gathers his
friends around the fire and explains to
him explains to them he man's planes his
his time machine and the explanation
involves a kind of lesson on science and
lesson about geometry and he says the
first thing I have to tell you is that
everything you think you know about
geometry is wrong they teach you that
there are three dimensions length
breadth and height but actually there's
a fourth dimension in the fourth
dimension this time and he explains this
to them and it's to them it's a new idea
and by to them I mean to Wells as
readers you know in the fiction he's
explaining it to his pals but of course
he's really explaining this brand-new
idea to the people of 19th century
England well to us that idea second
nature right we you know time is the
fourth dimension and everybody knows
that we don't exactly learn it in
kindergarten but um but almost and and
it's odd that Einstein was ten years
after Wells that is Einstein's very
first presentation of the special theory
of relativity was ten years after Wells
as time machine so what am i what am I
trying to say here I am NOT trying to
say that Einstein got this idea from
Wells that would be well I mean that
would be great if there were any
evidence for it but there isn't any
evidence for that and and and and it
would be silly to say that I'm also not
trying to say that Wells was such a
genius that he about physics that he
anticipated these ideas before well he
did anticipate them but he wasn't he
wasn't putting forward a theory of
physics he was not it he never dreamed
that ten years later this would be a new
orthodoxy of of the most important
science that
that the professionals were discussing
he thought he was making up a story he
thought he was trying to invent a
plausible excuse for this piece of
fantastic storytelling that he wanted to
sell it was his first book he was a
young striving writer trying to make a
buck and for the rest of his life
he lived a long time and he lived
through an era when relativity became
well understood and the time as the
fourth dimension became a recognized
concept and people started to take
time-travel seriously and those people
were were generally disappointed in
Welles himself because Welles never did
time-travel again he never cooperated
with people who wanted to say you know
could time-travel be real how could we
do it he always said you know don't
don't you guys know I'm just telling a
story and so he disappointed his fans as
no doubt I'm gonna disappoint my fans
when when they buy my book hoping to
discover the secrets of time travel